TWELFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MEETING OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE. I WANNA FIRST START
BY THANKING ALL THE STAFF OF
MADE A RETURN BACK TO THE
CAPITOL TO HEARING BILLS
POSSIBLE DUE TO COVER NINETEEN
CONSIDERATIONS WERE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITAL. SO WE CAN ONLY
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF FOLKS
PARTICIPATE IN THE HEARING. IN
PERSON WE'RE ALSO REQUIRING
THAT MASS BE WORN AND PHYSICAL
DISTANCING BE MAINTAINED-
WEATHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
A VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. IT IS THE
CUSTOM AND PRACTICE OF THE
HOUSE THE MEMBERS BE PROPERLY
ATTIRED- AND FOR OUR HEARING
WERE IN A MASK IS ONE OF THE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE BEEN PROPERLY
ATTIRED WE HAVE TO BILLS AND
AGENDA ONE BILLS ON CONSENT
EACH BUILDING OF TO ME
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION EACH MAIN WITNESS
CAN HAVE UP TO TWO MINUTES
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT FOR ALL
OTHER WITNESSES CALLING IN TO
REGISTER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
WE ASK THAT YOU ONLY STATE YOUR
NAME. YOUR ORGANIZATION AND
YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL IF
YOU SAY MORE THAN THAT THAT THE
OPERATOR WILL CUT YOU OFF. IF
YOU'RE UNABLE TO GET THROUGH ON
THE PHONE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE PORTAL ON THE
ASSEMBLY ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. THIS WILL BECOME PART
OF THE OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE
BILL YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT AN
EMAIL TO COMMITTEE STAFF. WE
HAVE SEVERAL OPTIONS FOR
TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC- IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AT THE PROPER TIME. I'LL
ASK YOU TO APPROACH AT THE
MICROPHONE. AND WE ASK THAT YOU
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE IN
ADDITION. FOLKS CAN TESTIFY
FROM THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATIONS WHICH ARE LOCATED ON
THE NORTH SIDES OF THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS. THOSE WITNESSES WILL
APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS
CAN WATCH THEIR TESTIMONY LIFE
WILL ALSO BE USING A MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE THROUGH WHICH
ANY WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A
BILL THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR
THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. ACCESS CODE. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO OH TWO
THIS NUMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND ON YOUR
TELEVISION SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOU'RE
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. IF YOUR
CONTENT PLEASE ELIMINATE ANY
BACKGROUND NOISE AND- BE
ADVISED IF YOU'RE A MAIN
WITNESS YOU REMAIN ON A
LIFELINE AND WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON
TO SPEAK. IF YOU HAVE ANY
ISSUES WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE YOU CAN CALL OUR
COMMITTEE AND 916-319-2085 ALSO
NOTE THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING
WRITTEN TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE
POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE RICHARD
EVANS UNDERSTANDING AT THIS
TIME WE ARE ONE. MEMBER SHORT
OF A QUORUM- BUT WE ARE GOING
TO PROCEED. TO HEAR. THE FIRST
ITEM WHICH IS FILE ITEM S. B.
THREE THIRTY WITH SENATOR
DORADO- SINCE WE GET A QUARREL
STYLE SHOULD BUT FOR NOW WE
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
AND WITH THAT. MADAM SENATOR
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING THANK YOU
CHAIR- GERMAN TO- I WANT TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENT
ALL RIGHT NOW COLLEAGUES
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA POSSESS EITHER
UNUSED REAL PROPERTY OR
FACILITIES THAT HAVE BECOME TOO
FINANCIALLY BURDENSOME TO
OPERATE SB THREE THIRTY WILL
CREATE A TEN YEAR PILOT PROGRAM
FOR THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT. THAT WILL
ENABLE THEM TO REPURPOSE SUCH
UNUSED SPACE INTO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS SB THREE
THIRTY AUTHORIZES THE- L. A. C.
C. D. TO ENTER INTO LEASES OR
AGREEMENTS WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES OR NON PROFITS. FOR
JOINT OCCUPANCY OF REAL
PROPERTY AND BUILDINGS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR STUDENTS
OR EMPLOYEES OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT THIS BILL
EXTENDS HOW LONG THE L. A. C.
C. D. MAY ENTER INTO A JOINT
OCCUPANCY AGREEMENT. THAT IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR DISTRICT STUDENTS
AND DOOR EMPLOYEES FROM FIVE
YEARS TO SIXTY SIX YEARS THIS
BILL ALSO ALLOWS L. A. C. C. D.
TO LEASE REAL PROPERTY FOR LESS
THAN FAIR RENTAL VALUE TO AN
ENTITY THAT INTENDS TO DEVELOP
AND OPERATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
FOR THE STUDENTS AND OUR
EMPLOYEES THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL ARE PERMISSIVE AND THEY
PROVIDE THE L. A. C. C. D. THE
MEANS TO ENTER INTO A JOINT
OCCUPANCY AGREEMENTS ONLY IF
SUCH AGREEMENT PROVIDES
POSITIVE SOLUTIONS TO THE
DISTRICTS NEEDS. COLLEAGUES
CALIFORNIA'S THE MIST OF THIS
CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
CANNOT JUST SERVE THE NEEDS OF
THE STUDENTS ACADEMICALLY IF
THEY WANT THE STUDENTS TO
SUCCEED WELL STUDENTS NEED
BASIC THINGS LIKE HOUSING
STABILITY AND FOOD SECURITY
THIS BILL HAS NO LISTED
OPPOSITION. AND TODAY SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL ON
BEHALF OF L. A. C. C. D. IS
ALEX ALANIZ THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE LET'S GO TO YOUR
PRINCIPAL WITNESS ALEX ALANIZ.
TO THE OPERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN CHU AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
ALEX FELONIES ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. WANT TO EXPRESS ALEX
CTV'S STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE THIRTY. IMPORTANT MEASURE
GIVES ALEX THE CD ESSENTIAL
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING
CRISIS FACING BOTH THE STUDENTS
AND EMPLOYEES OF THE DISTRICT
THE BILL ESTABLISHES A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR LACC DUE TO ENTER
INTO LEASES OR AGREEMENTS WITH
PRIVATE ENTITIES FOR JOINT
OCCUPANCY OF REAL PROPERTY AND
BUILDING. FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FOR STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT ASSENTOS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT IS
PROUD TO HAVE ONE OF THE
LARGEST AND MOST DIVERSE
STUDENT BODIES WITH OVER TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED EACH YEAR.
OUR STUDENTS COME FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE BRING DIFFERENT
LIFE EXPERIENCES INCLUDING
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND. IN
COLLEGE PROMISED STUDENTS
REPRESENTING THE FIRST TO EVER
GO TO COLLEGE FOR STUDENTS
RETURNING FOR A SECOND CHANCE.
NEARLY 50% OF L. A. C. C. D.
STUDENTS ARE BETWEEN THE AGES
OF TWENTY AND THIRTY FOUR. THIS
STUDENT GROUP IS MOST
VULNERABLE TO ACADEMIC STARTS
AND STOPS AND YET MEANS THE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES LACC
OFFERS THE MOST TAKING THE
CRITICAL STEP TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL CAN BE EASILY DERAILED
BECAUSE OF A HEART ISSUE AND
WORK SCHEDULE CONFLICTS WITH
THE CLASS OR RENT INCREASE AS
OF JANUARY OF THIS YEAR WENT TO
LOS ANGELES WERE ON AVERAGE TWO
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
FOUR DOLLARS ONLY 1% OF RENTAL
TODAY ARE BETWEEN SEVEN HUNDRED
ONE DOLLARS AND ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS OVER ONE THIRD OF
RENTERS A LOS ANGELES PAY MORE
THAN HALF OF THEIR MONTHLY
INCOME ON RENT THIS WILL
PROVIDE DALY CCD THE
FLEXIBILITY TO ENTER INTO A
JOINT OCCUPANCY PARTNERSHIP
WITH A RESPONSIBLE THIRD PARTY
DEVELOPER THAT SHARE OUR COMMON
GOAL OF PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
SUBSIDIZED RENTAL UNITS UNDER
THIS PILOT PROGRAM LACC THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
LAND AND RETAIN ALL OTHER
PROTECTIONS CURRENTLY OFFERED
BY STATUTE. IF THE PARTNERSHIP
IS TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT MAKES AN EXCEPTION
FOR REQUIRE THE HIGHEST
MONETARY RATE OF RETURN. THE
PROVIDING THE LAND AT A NOMINAL
COST ALLEY CCP TO CONTROL ONE
FACTOR THE MANY THAT CONTRIBUTE
TO THE EVER INCREASING COST TO
BUILD IN CALIFORNIA ACCORDING
TO THE TURNER CENTER FOR A
HOUSING INNOVATION AT UC
BERKELEY. COST TO BUILD ONE OF
PORTABLE HOUSING UNIT COST
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. THE COST OF LAND IS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTORS THE OVERALL
DEVELOPMENT COSTS WE CAN REDUCE
THE COST OF HOUSING FOR
EMPLOYEES AND STUDENTS DEVIATE
HOUSING AND SECURITY BURDEN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT YOU VOTE
AYE ON SB THREE THIRTY AS
AMENDED IN THE ANALYSIS THANK
YOU THANK YOU BEFORE WE PROCEED
I'M GOING TO ESTABLISH QUORUM
MADAM SECRETARY TO HEAR TO HEAR
IF THEY ARE STILL HERE THE
SEATTLE GABRIELLE GABRIEL HERE
KALRA. HOLLERING FIELD KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN BURKE SILVER CREEK
SILVA HERE WEEKS WE HAVE QUORUM
AT THIS TIME WE JUST HEARD FROM
THE MAIN PRINCIPLE WITNESS
SINCE THERE'S NO OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WILL OPEN IT UP TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- AND I THINK I
SEE ONE PERSON HERE THE CHAMBER
SPEAKING I ASSUME IN FAVOR THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. AND AFFILIATION FOR
THE RECORD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL THANKFUL FOR THE
SUPPORT OF THE CENTER FOR THIS
BUT AND THIS BILL. IT MAKE SURE
MORE FOR CONSTRUCTION WORKERS-
LOOKING FORWARD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT LET US
GO TO THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION IS EARNING ONE OF THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION. THAT
WISHES TO SPEAK AND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THE BILL SEE NON
LET'S GO NOW TO THE OPERATOR
HOW TO THE OPERATOR LET'S FIRST
HEAR FROM MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THE WISH TO SUPPORT THE BILL IF
YOU COULD JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION TO THE OPERATOR.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO ASSIST SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE THIRTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE
END ZERO. AT THIS TIME
CURRENTLY WE DO HAVE THREE
COMMENTS IN ARM SORRY FOR
COMMENTS IN Q. OUR FIRST
COMMENT COMES FROM MINE TWENTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS CHRIS
HANNON WITH THE LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY'S BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORTING. S. B. THREE
THIRTY THANK YOU. NINE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD THIS CLIP SCHMIDT THE
BUSINESS MANAGER WITH UNITED
UNION OF ROOFERS WATER PREFERS
ALLIES TRAITS LOCAL THIRTY SIX
IN LOS ANGELES AND WE ALSO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING.
NINE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE AT TONYA
SANCHEZ BUT I B. W. LOCAL UP
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY- AND WE
STAND SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD YES GOOD
MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
CAESAR PORTHOS WITH TEAMSTERS
LOCAL NINE EIGHTY SIX HERE'S MY
LAKE COUNTY AND WE'RE ALL
SUPPORT OF THE SB THREE THIRTY.
THANK YOU LINE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YEAH
THIS IS MITCH BONTA THE OUR
WORKERS FOR THREE THREE LOS
ANGELES AND WE ARE SUPPORT OF%
SB THREE THIRTY THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LET ME NOW ASK
THE OPERATOR TO OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
THIRTY. YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE THIRTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE HAVE NO COME ONE
MOMENT WE DO HAVE A COMMENTED
Q. ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GET TO
THE LINE NUMBER.
NINE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK I WAS PUT INTO
THE WRONG QUEUE BUT BY MEANS
FRANCISCO ARGUE WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL ELEVEN
I'M SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THIRTY. FIVE FOR THE
CONFUSION. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT INTO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU COLLEAGUES A
SPRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE I
WANT TO THANK THE GOOD SENATOR
FOR. REALLY LEADING THE EFFORTS
TO INCREASE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR OUR- LOWER INCOME STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITYCOLLEGE WORKFORCE
I THINK WE KNOW THAT FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
THERE'S JUST A HUGE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO. ARE EITHER
HOMELESS OR BEEN AFFECTED THE
HOMELESS IN RECENT YEARS AND I
THINK ANY ACTION WE CAN TAKE.
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD IS
IMPORTANT AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE- THIS CREATIVE IDEA
TO MOVE FORWARD WITH IN LA AND
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS A
GOOD STRONG CONSENSUS ITEM-
WITHOUT ANY FIND. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CORPS
OF YES I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR- THIS IS NOT ONLY A
CREATIVE SOLUTION IT'S
PRAGMATIC AND IT BRINGS. US
SOME OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
TOGETHER- THAT WE NEED IN ORDER
TO MOVE FORWARD ON HOUSING
PROJECTS. I TO HOST A- IN MY
OWN DISTRICT FULLERTON COLLEGE
IN CYPRESS COLLEGE VERY. WELL
ATTENDED COLLEGES BUT WE KNOW
IN THIS LAST YEAR. BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC THAT SOME OF OUR
ENROLLMENT DROPPED AND SO
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO. TO GET
OUR STUDENTS BACK TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES GET THEM
HOUSED IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
POSSIBLY. STEALING YOUR IDEA
AND SEEING IF WE CAN DO A MODEL
IN ORANGE COUNTY- AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANKS SO MUCH. IS
THAT A MOTION MOVED FOR. MOTION
WITH OUR ANSWER SECOND THERE'S
A SECOND ANY OTHER COMMENTS TO
VICE CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
BILL AND- I WANTED TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. THE FINANCING
STRUCTURE FOR DOING. IT FOR
CARRYING THIS OUT. BECAUSE PART
OF THE AS YOU POINTED OUT PART
OF THE HOUSING ISSUE IS THE
LAND COSTS AND THAT'S A LARGE
PART OF WHY COST FIVE HUNDRED.
THOUSAND DOLLARS A UNIT TO
BUILD THINGS SO WHAT GETS USED
AFTER THAT IS A PROBLEM NINETY
EIGHT MONEY THEY GET USED TO
BUILD IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE GONNA
CLEAR THE LAND AND BUILD NEW
UNITS THAT'S ONE THING IF
YOU'RE GOING TO CONVERT ANOTHER
THING THAT'S ANOTHER COST ARE
WE STILL USING PROP NINETY
EIGHT MONEY FOR THAT OR ARE WE
USING MONEY THAT IS DESIGNATED
IN OUR IN OUR GENERAL FUND FOR-
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING. TO BE
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH THAT BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK A LOT OF
TAXPAYERS ARE REALLY CONCERNED
THAT PROP IN THE PROPER NINETY
EIGHT TAKES A LOT OF MONEY OUT
OF AND THEN PUT IT IN EDUCATION
IS SUPPOSED TO BE USED FOR
EDUCATION NOT THE HOUSING PART
SO IF EDUCATION HAS LAND AND
THEY WANT TO PARTNER UP THE
MONEY FOR THAT SHOULD COME FROM
OUR GENERAL FUND. THAT IT AND
NOT PROP NINETY EIGHT FIVE.
YEAH SO THAT'S MY QUESTION IS
WE ARE USING PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS TO ACTUALLY BUILD- I
DON'T NOT THINK SO I'M- ALMOST
POSITIVE- BUT LET ME ASK-
MISTER ALAN THESE TO. BE MORE
SPECIFIC WITH THAT QUESTION
OKAY THANKS ALLEN EAST IF YOU
COULD ANSWER THAT PLEASE THE
SOURCES OF FUNDING GOOD
MORNING- YEAH GOOD MORNING IT'S
AN IMMENSELY ART OUT OF IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S A
LITTLE THAT THE JOINT OCCUPANCY
IS WORKING WITH THE OPPORTUNITY
COLLEGE AND THE PRIVATE ENTITY
THAT'S GOING TO SUCH A B. WE
HAVE AN AYE BUILDING. OUR
BUILDING ON ON LAND THAT'S ON
THAT'S NOT BEING USED AT THIS
MOMENT IT IS NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT PROP NINETY
EIGHT MONEY'S GOING TO BE USED-
BUT I DON'T STATE SPECIFICALLY
ONE OR THE OTHER- IF YOU LOCKED
UP TODAY I COULD CHECK RESEARCH
THAT AND GET BACK TO YOU BY
TODAY. ACCORDING THIS REPORT
OUT- AND- BUT AT THAT POINT I
DON'T THINK SO BUT I DON'T WANT
TO- TAPER CERTAIN WHETHER
THAT'S THECASE BUT IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT IT'S NOT
BEING APARTMENT IT MIGHT NOT BE
USED. FOR THIS PARTICULAR.
PROJECT I THANK YOU FOR THAT
BUT WOULD HAVE TO CLEAR IF FOR
ME TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE. SO I LIKE THE IDEA I
LIKE BEING ABLE TO HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHERE- WHERE
KIDS EIGHT GUARDS ARE MORE
CENTRALLY LOCATED NEXT TO AN
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITY LIKE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. A LOT OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE YOU KNOW
I WENT TO ONE- AND IT'S BECAUSE
I LIVED IN THE AREA WHERE. IT
WAS AND THAT'S WHAT THEY DO IS
THEY THEY DRAW FROM THE
COMMUNITY SO A LOT OF KIDS DO
HAVE HOUSING. BUT THE ONES THAT
DON'T ARE THE ONES THAT WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND HAVING
HOUSING THAT IS CENTRAL TO THE
COLLEGE SO THEY CAN HAVE PURSUE
SOME EDUCATION GOALS. IS
LAUDABLE WE JUST HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE USING
EDUCATION MONEY FOR EDUCATION
AND- AFFORDABLE HOUSING MONEY
FOR THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
THAT'S NOT REALLY SPELLED OUT.
IN THIS AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE
IT TO BE SPELLED OUT THANK YOU
I APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'LL JUST
ADD THAT IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT- THAT THE MAIN WITNESS WAS
CORRECT THAT THIS WOULD NOT BE
DRAWN ON PROP NINETY EIGHT
FUNDS IT WOULD. INVOLVE
TRADITIONAL FORMAL HOUSING
FINANCING TYPICALLY WITH THE
PARTNERS THAT WOULD BE WORKING
WITH L. A. C. C. D. ON THIS AND
THAT WOULD INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE
FEDERAL TAX CREDIT DOLLARS
THAT. HAVE STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT- BUT I'M SURE THE
AUTHOR CAN CLARIFY THAT AND-
GET A GOOD ANSWER BACK TO THE
MOISTURE CAN ANY OTHER COMMENTS
TO THE CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YOUR SUPPORT ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM
SECRETARY. CAN YOU. FIVE. THEY
ARE NOW I CALDERON. PROBABLY.
HI I THINK. THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
SENATOR OUR COLLEAGUE WE HAVE A
SECOND ITEM IT IS OKAY IT'S ON
CONSENT ISLAND S. J. R. SIX- BY
CENTER WINNER TO BIPARTISAN
MEASURE- COULD I MOTION TO MOVE
THIS ITEM FOR. THEIR SECOND.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY. OKAY
HI HI. CHOLERA ALL AYE KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
CORK SILVA KIRKSVILLE FIVE
WEEKS WEEKS BY FILING TWO
PASSES AND LET'S JUST CIRCLE
BACK TO FILE AND ONE I THINK WE
HAVE ONE MEMBER WHO DID HAVE A
CHANCE TO VOTE ON THAT MR
MAIENSCHEIN FOR FILING OF ONE
SB THREE THIRTY. NUMBER
MAIENSCHEIN I AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS FOR THE
DAY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU. I
THINK WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR MR
KILEY FOR FEW MINUTES HOPEFULLY
HE WILL ARRIVE.